on Instagram your title is listed as
prompt engineer right
thank you for noticing
there's uh I don't know if it's ironic
or uh non
uh or sarcastic or not uh what do you
think of prompt engineering as a
scientific and Engineering discipline or
maybe and maybe art form you know what
I started comma six years ago I started
the tiny Corp a month ago
so much has changed
I'm now like
I started like going through like
similar comma processes to like starting
a company I'm like okay I'm gonna get an
office in San Diego I'm gonna bring
people here
I don't think so I think I'm actually
gonna do remote
right George you're gonna do remote you
hate remote yeah but I'm not going to do
job interviews the only way you're going
to get a job is if you contribute to the
GitHub right and then like it like like
interacting through GitHub
like like GitHub being the real like
project management software for your
company and the thing pretty much just
is a GitHub repo
is like showing me kind of what the
future of okay so a lot of times I'll go
on a Discord or kind of grad Discord and
I'll throw out some random like hey you
know can you change instead of having
log and X as LL Ops change it to log 2
and x two
it's pretty small change you can just
use like change your base formula
um that's the kind of task that I can
see in AI being able to do in a few
years
like in a few years I could see myself
describing that and then within 30
seconds a pull request is up that does
it and it passes my CI and I merge it
right so I really started thinking about
like well what is the future of
jobs how many AIS can I employ at my
company as soon as we get the first Tiny
Box up I'm going to stand up a 65b llama
in the Discord and it's like yeah here's
the Tiny Box he's just like he's
chilling with us
basically
I mean like you said with niches like
most human jobs
will eventually be replaced with prompt
engineering well prompt engineering kind
of is this like
as you like move up the stack right like
okay there used to be humans actually
doing um arithmetic by hand I think they
used to be like big forms of people
doing doing pluses and stuff right and
then you have like spreadsheets right
and then okay the spreadsheet can do the
Plus for me and then you have like
macros right and then you have like
things that basically just are
spreadsheets under the hood right like
like accounting software
um
as we move further up the abstraction
what's at the top of the abstraction
stack well the prompt engineer
yeah right what is what is the last
thing if you think about like humans
wanting to keep control
well what am I really in the company but
a prompt engineer right is there a
certain point where the AI will be
better at writing prompts
yeah but you see the problem with the AI
writing prompts a definition that I
always liked of AI was AI is the do what
I mean machine
AI is not the like the computer is so
pedantic it does what you say so
but you want the Do What I Mean Machine
yeah right you want the machine where
you say you know get my grandmother out
of the burning house it like reasonably
takes your grandmother and puts her on
the ground not lifts her a thousand feet
above the burning house and lets her
fall right but yeah but
uh is not going to find the meaning I
mean to do what I mean it has to figure
stuff out sure and
the thing you'll maybe ask it to do is
run government for me oh and do what I
mean very much comes down to how aligned
is that AI with you of course when you
talk to an AI That's made by a big
company in the cloud the AI
fundamentally is aligned to them not to
you yeah and that's why you have to buy
a tiny box so you make sure the AI stays
aligned to you every time that they
start to pass you know AI regulation or
GPU regulation I'm going to see sales of
tiny boxes Spike all right it's gonna be
like guns right every time they talk
about gun regulation boom gun sales so
in the space of AI you're an anarchist
anarchism
espouser unbeliever I'm an informational
Anarchist yes I'm an informational
Anarchist and a physical statist
ICS I do not think Anarchy in the
physical world is very good because I
exist in the physical world but I think
we can construct this virtual world
where Anarchy it can't hurt you right I
love that Tyler the Creator uh tweet uh
yo cyber bullying isn't real man have
you tried turn it off the screen close
your eyes like yeah
but how do you
prevent the AI from basically replacing
all human prompt Engineers well there's
it's like a self like where nobody is
the problem engineer anymore so autonomy
greater and greater autonomy until it's
full autonomy yeah
and that's just where it's headed
because one person is going to say
run everything for me you see
I look at potential Futures and as long
as the AIS go on to create a vibrant
civilization with diversity and
complexity Across the Universe
more power to them I'll die
um if the AIS go on to actually like
turn the world into paper clips and then
they die out themselves well that's
horrific and we don't want that to
happen
so this is what I mean about like
robustness I trust robust machines the
current AIS are so not robust like this
comes back to the idea that we've never
made a machine that can self-replicate
okay but when we have if the machines
are truly robust and there is one prompt
engineer left in the world
hope you're doing good man hope you
believe in God like you know
you know it'll go by God and
go go forth and and conquer the universe